right there yeah boy okay Oh doesn't it
let me do some sucka be hell on sight
and throw knives and bullets on
I don't knew that it's just when you see
one you're suspicious you're something
else that's what I sound like thank you
hi well hello
oh it's the cafeteria yeah there's water
man for me yeah you wait I'm here take
my watermelon you take my watermelon are
you the bitter air oh you are whoa bot
oh well I guess God guys the guns gone
sorry we got it oh my we only have our
melons if we can just drag them with our
melons together
wait no hold one melon wait come on over
there good Ramon okay I'm gonna put this
melon from your chest and you're gonna
sit there not gonna be they need to be
at the same level
hang on I'm working on it okay you're a
card already so we're gonna defferent oh
yeah now is you with two twins we're
gonna seduce you guys hey they went they
went that way mark went to go have the
fan fiction reenactment over there the
court wait a minute what is is higher
than the other god it's easy don't you
know I'm sorry Susie these are perfectly
natural they went out the door yeah I
sell them for reals it oh now I have
three boobs are like wooden half is good
right what is your friend running away I
sure did not her toys and lubricants to
give you a good time no don't eat you
bad siloam is this it's an interesting
island from the 41 herstory
oh oh oh now you're sitting duck Jesus
way those terrible idea okay John that
was a terrible shot such a dick oh I
can't shut my dick hole okay I'm at the
mouth cuz you suck dick Oh
you can't set that either there's too
much Dickens oh yeah what do you think
are gonna suck all these dicks
there's just lining up I gotta get
through somehow
you could hit up you know it's - Wow
wait your eyes but whatever wait if you
just accepted our offer you could have
had like one and a half sets of boobs
I couldn't you want to run away melon
action it was half more boobs than you
have right now that big advanced until
one of them became higher than the other
one my fault jack was fiddling okay it's
not fiddling okay whose fiddling well
smoke those I was acting through my body
takes two to tango but I guess a lot of
sure you want to try this out test your
might go ahead long answer hey Monica oh
I found a gun yay and melons and melons
now I've got all the milk hey I got the
money and the pot better jack see me do
the jack all those right on your face
this is a fondant just pick up the melon
I can't shoot through a melon so just
put the melon in front of you you'll be
family fine oh did you grab a melon you
didn't get the melon you got the knife
you got in the melon I confuse melons
and knives all the time
what me do right yeah bro I wish I had
more than one melon happen hello melon
friend did you come for the melons I
can't belong as well like I just died
Melanie's a felon
it was probably a natural causes hey you
want a melon with someone down here stop
your show yeah we diet we three the
three melon lady from Total Recall yeah
with our Ellen's combined I could be the
one hard one melon lady from kung pao
anybody fine Gillis okay
what
you ain't coming here no I was giving
him a chance since I was giving him a
chance to give up peacefully but he
didn't take it oddly enough it was like
I hit in the face with Nick's melon
oh-ho-oh innuendos mmm
what would a balanced mind guru what the
Ravens know we're all having fun as
friends together and dispersed at each
other without stabbing them look how
high can you throw these out the
breaking hook ah man I gotta go up in
the railing they grab ya wait how do I
need to go up in the river there make
the gracious toss of our time
yeah try to throw your watermelons and
I'll try to stab them in midair good I
like this idea
okay go get a melon overthrow yeah I got
a skate like right here for that to work
I don't know I won't murder you until
all the water melons are impressive of
the guy with the gun was able to do this
but not me right here we'll have that
here I'll try it all right yeah all
right I'm good three two one boom well I
wasn't an eye at the same time it was me
oh good
ha ha ha bump to yours public me with
watermelons like it's it's Laureus but I
need fire you know you picture this
you sit on the flippers going first I
first like job
we're on line 8 2 1 fire that's terrible
ok now I turn gotta count for the last
one go Oh swing swing like a quarter
second sooner 3 2 1 Oh
I was like right there for you pathetic
that wasn't funny
alright I got the gun I'm gonna shoot
him out of here there's gonna be more
offensive I'll see if I can shake it
Frank hey you ready but what Cobden [ __ ]
I try to shoot a melon I'm blind where
am i what happened I'm gonna beat you
with Bella when you're on the gun right
am i I don't think I can pick it up they
okay did I gotta who got it's gonna
blind that's okay
all right here we go I'm uh throws right
ah she weighed hot [ __ ] I feel like I
should say something away this would be
a terrible place to get murdered a yeah
what mm oh it sounded so convincing
though my truck wait for something big
striving at that's right really hard
sometimes it just doesn't come out you
know oh hey that penis oh yes Bravo I'm
turning my back it would be a horrible
place to get honest why would you try to
teabag me I'm trying to get murdered
here I just want someone to stop me in
the behind oh well yes can you have him
do anything right well I will mark was a
lawyer did what a giver he was talking a
person was moving I shot that are you
serious I thought I should oh my god why
I bought it yeah I'm sure that's a great
time to get here
okay wait last year it was me haha I was
delusion and deception maybe three us
this